Don do you think the word fiance is
cringe oh it's disgusting uh uh I didn't
until right now
could you say my fiance like with your
whole Channel I don't know what is there
like a etymology of fiance and by the
way I just realized that fiance for a
woman has two E's yeah and for a man I
don't like it one day
that's wild why do I get an extra I did
not know this
slugs we have the biggest announcement
of Our Lives pinch ourselves pinch
yourself he ain't dreaming
we are finally here today to tell you
that on September 12th the day after you
oh Annie that's not relevance
you can finally get trust Tuesday merch
and it's so cute it's cute cool awesome
designs each of these are available just
click the link below
we have look kalila and are modeling
them in extra larges that we're wearing
as dresses I'm wearing a small tank top
and it's my favorite tank top I've ever
owned I love it so much it's so cute I
wore it on stage last night everybody
loved it
um we're so excited about our new merch
we're going to be wearing it 24 7
because we can't believe it took us two
years to get here these are so comfy so
cute cut them crop them
and then go out in the world and meet
other slugs and talk about skull you
know what to do
where us you guys I'm packing my bags
and I'm leaving this town what no I mean
I have a show oh my God I have shows
this week this Thursday there are still
tickets for The Late Show in Washington
DC
and Saturday night in Boston at the
Wilbur I'm so ugly wait will my necklace
may be prettier no okay so get tickets
at Esther andice.com and then after that
literally the next week San Diego
Chicago Detroit oh my god get tickets at
astronauties.com I can't wait
hey sluggies Welcome to our new set
we're so excited so many fun things
coming I am on the road as always I'll
be in Austin Texas at the Vulcan October
6th and 7th I'm going to be in La Jolla
shooting my comedy special October 13th
and 14th I'll be in San Jose California
at The Improv November 17th and 18th and
Houston Texas December 15th and 16th I
am always adding dates so go to
annieleterman.com shows for tickets
thank you to our sponsor rocket Money
Stop wasting money on things you don't
use cancel your unwanted subscriptions
and manage your money the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
that's rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday head to
factormeals.com trash50 and use code
trash50 to get 50 off that's code
trash50 at factormeals.com trash50 to
get 50 off thank you to our sponsors
prize picks go to prizefix.com Tuesday
and use code trash Tuesday for a first
deposit match of up to a hundred dollars
all lower case that's prize picks.com
trash Tuesday and use code trash Tuesday
for a first deposit match of up to a
hundred dollars guys prize picks daily
fantasy sports made easy
um you guys welcome to another episode
of trash Tuesday Esther is being
replaced by a very very special person a
real man we wanted a real man on here he
is a friend of ours he is a son of Los
Angeles by way of Argentina and Mexico
um he is a rapper actor stand up um he
does it all
um everyone our friend dumbfounded hey
what's up everybody you love those
credits with his scroll we had to unroll
this long long oh wait and you you
podcast you have a podcast with Stephie
who I love Yeah and Rick it's caught fun
with dumb yeah you guys are killing it
yeah it's good it's fun pop thanks for
having me yeah thanks for being here are
you still jet lagged from Korea I'm a
little jet lagged yeah I well the only
reason is I threw a party uh the night
before I flew out from Korea in Korea it
was lit and then yesterday I had to make
it to a show a comedy shot though every
month
was the party with like friends you have
in Korea or was it just you friends as
dumbfounded and people came nah like
friends too I have like you know some
K-pop friends DJ friends actor friends
over there and we just threw a big thing
with Nora Nora was there too yeah and
then so Random like simulu had like a
layover it was like Shang Chi there
it was like weird like random people
showed up Annie are you hardcore
formaling right now I'm this one sounds
very fun I wish I was involved I I mean
I know you through Nora through Aquafina
have you gone to Asia no I have not and
her fiance is from Laos there's been a
lot of Asian
and if recently I know and and in nine
to 12 months I will be full Asian yeah I
can't wait but honestly though once you
marry into an Asian family you are
technically I already called Mom my
mother-in-law I've gotten so much fun I
feel like
I don't know I don't want to say I'm in
I don't but I feel in yeah I mean and
Laos too that's a whole nother section I
want I mean I I said I floated the idea
of having like a destination wedding and
now Todd's mom has just been sending me
all this stuff about having a wedding
and but where would it be in Laos I'm
not going that far I'm not I think you
should no no no I actually think a
wedding in Laos is so out of the box and
ridiculously Annie that I think you
should do it wow I mean you could have
been there aren't they she's just cheap
there like when I get married or if I
get married it's gonna be in the
Philippines because my dollar really
stretches no I definitely like the
stretching of the dollar I like that you
can have like a huge wedding on a very
small wedding's budget yes I just wanted
to boo hell yeah yeah yeah yeah what did
you think it was good it was like a
music festival there it was like monsoon
season but so that part sucked when'd
you go
it was a couple months it was I want to
say like four or five months ago earlier
Festival what is it no no I don't know
what it was but there was all these like
Filipino stores are you going to Asia
like multiple times a year I just I
don't I don't like the stage right now I
like it over there more honestly I would
have delay extended my flight wait did
you only go to Cebu you didn't go
anywhere else no I just went there but I
recently went to uh Thailand I went to
Korea uh Japan
I want all of that I want to go
everywhere I was telling them I went um
on Google Maps I went to Japan on a date
oh yeah you guys so how does that work
again you could just walk on the streets
we just walked around the streets we
picked out restaurants we would have
gone to oh that is really sweet is it
sweet I mean
is the best idea ever
yeah my boy had like a ketamine lollipop
with I was like it's a K-pop that's what
it is that's what it was called yeah it
was called the K-pop that is one drug
that I feel I could actually be addicted
to because I last year I actually got
deliberately put in a k-hole to treat
like depression and anxiety yeah and it
was such a up experience but like
I've I never felt better I've like all
of my anxiety like melted away like the
months after that so I was like oh maybe
this is the drug for me but during when
I was in the camp it was the worst thing
it was terrifying
the hottest girls do ketamine I feel
really hard you say that no it's like a
full compliment I can't I got sponsored
on my other podcast like it was I was
like manifestation is real my ads lady
was like what are you what are your
interests when she was like what should
I get you sponsored by I go I just was
like oh I like spray tans and ketamine
and I was like you know kind of kidding
oh my God the ketamine Clinics of L.A
don't they sponsor like three ways we
gotta get sponsored on here I got
sponsored on my other one
for ketamine yes I'm a ketamine sponsor
wait we need this I didn't know that
this was as long as it's not like we're
not pushing recreational ketamine no no
no no no because k-pops are recreational
Academy it was definitely yeah
ketamine's never been my thing
yeah no no and I don't want to go into
what my things
that it was never my thing
what does that mean nobody that's an
academy and puts things in the way of
getting their ketamine I think that's
what ketamine was ruined for me because
I thought it was something else oh it's
happened I got deeply okay everyone has
had that moment what do you think it is
and it looks like hope yeah this look
like we're talking about this was years
ago we don't condone these drugs these
are horrible drugs you should never do
them ever but this happened ever they
should put some food coloring for safety
or something it does look very similar
and so the amounts that you do are very
different and The Vibes and the feelings
you get from them are very different so
if you do like a a cocaine line size of
ketamine yeah you can't do that in a
world you're gonna be slumped you are
not oh really president you're gone yeah
you gotta take different yeah yeah yeah
I mean that happened to me in high
school and it was actually 2000 year
2000 New Years
I was at my friend's older sister's
place we were 16 and I did that they
brought us like a bowl a plate and I
thought it was cocaine and I did
this huge thing of ketamine and I ended
up I had to drive that some guy came and
kicked the window in yeah it was just
like in Philly and some random guy just
came in and got a fight with someone and
bashed the window and they were like
everyone out and we're like the kid even
the kids
and they're like the children gone I'm
like cause I guess like half of
them so like definitely you guys leave
and I remember having to drive like
coming down from a k-hole and I was
knocked over so many things that like my
homegirl's apartment just in a Kaho and
then I turned on her water machine and I
left it on overnight and it flooded her
whole place
and that's just so mad because the
filter water machine you know she had it
was filtered so it was filtered water
flooded but you know that I almost died
by death of a refrigerator because of
something Bobby did that was similar did
he think your refrigerator with your
shoulders
yeah wait wasn't there a football player
that was called the refrigerator I don't
know
I posted a video icebox was from the
Little Giants
dream I posted a video kalila maybe
three months ago I wasn't in my best
shape okay somebody told me I looked
like a mini fridge
in the comments I was like wow I was
like at least I said Minnie see William
Perry Oh yeah yeah yeah but icebox was a
girl on Little Giants which was one of
my favorite movies ever but I mean I
liked Sandlot I was a baseball Oh
Yeah Yeah Sandlot was cute cute but ice
ice box that girl was like she was such
a cream dream because she had that she
was pretty but she was a tomboy and she
played football you're like there's hope
for me I was like There's Hope for these
shoulders someone's gonna want
to want me one day but um so Bobby was
uh doing yoga online one day and I had
left the house and when I came back I
it's it sounded like someone was taking
a shower upstairs but I knew that he was
still in the room doing yoga I was like
what the is that sound it sounds
like water and I go upstairs and I guess
the cats had like moved the faucet over
this way and it had been on for like an
hour and a half yeah and so the whole
upstairs was flooded and he was just
Namaste so
completely unaware that his home was
flooding and so they had to redo all of
the floors but they had to unbolt this
like massive Thermador fridge
um from the wall like during
construction of the new floor right and
I forgot that it was not bolted and I
opened the fridge and the whole thing
like came down on me oh man and I swear
to you like I it was like a refrigerator
crushing
a bad way to go and then Bobby I was
like how as an Asian woman too it's like
so disrespectful I know he pulled it to
die in the kitchen
and um yeah but it took like two other
people to get me out from under the
fridge and had like kimchi on the whole
time Bobby's still doing yoga he's like
I'm almost done babe
oh my God but um but yeah that was a
very scary imagine if you had heard that
I had passed
like how did she go like I would never
like I hope no one would actually tell
you the truth I would rather you say
like she was found in an Alleyway just
like she had OD'd and was gang banged it
up I'm actually so scared of this way
that I think you might die can you not
say it because I actually believe these
things don't I'm just gonna tell you
right now it's gonna be a drowning
of sorts don't you date anyone you dive
with I saw the movie I saw that
movie about what happened to that girl
where she was married her coach that was
helping her with the free Dives she was
doing the trying to get the Guinness
Book of World Records oh God I don't
know what that is please look up what's
this girl's name there they they had a
movie about it
um that I watched on Netflix but then
it's based on a true story so this this
guy was a was a professional
um
Freedom diet free diver where they would
you know they put the weights down and
they go whatever is that what you do
yeah we'll do the weights and try to go
down no I don't compete and freedom
balloon no so it sucks you up those
people they just go straight down and
they try to hit records for how how far
they can go I spear fish but it requires
me to still free dive to the bottom okay
so he was messing with her balloon the
husband was messing with her balloon at
the end no then all of a sudden there
was no air to blow the balloon up and
she so she just had to float up her own
speed and died and no one could help her
she had like a blackout yeah but there
was no but there was no air for the
balloon and then so but no one could
could investigate because you need
wherever this happened I think it was in
Puerto Rico you have to have the family
ask for the investigation so nobody
investigated but they think that her
husband was planning thought he could
save her because he thought it was going
to be a thing where there'd be like this
romantic where he saves his wife wait
that's why he wanted to do it that's
what they think that's the theory
because so you didn't have like a you
know sancha on the side that he wanted
to like Live Well the movie the movie
which is Loosely based on this story
made it seem like she was
that um he had caught her cheating on
him and he was cheating on her and he
was done with her and it was this whole
thing but I don't know why you would
kill her if that's the case but but they
said that when she came up he started
giving her mouth to mouth in the water
which like that's so weird you would
bring her on the boat to do it you
wouldn't be unstable in the water doing
it and they thought that that was very
performative and that so they thought
that it was
um that he was trying to do a publicity
stunt where it's like husband saves wife
but she actually didn't make it and she
was was she in a bad mood she was in a
bad mood before she and not a regular
mood that she usually is in before she
does oh all right these crime docs
never really you know give a clear
answer to these this wasn't even I
didn't see a documentary I saw like a
like a fictional movie yeah there she is
Audrey Master that's the last pictures
of her oh you saw like a lifetime movie
situation yeah it was like uh it was a
foreign film it was on you know it's so
funny I was looking at steamy
like
cinemaxy movies and that was one of them
oh skinnymax I mean I still love uh
steamy cinematics yeah you get so horny
it's so like it's so like nostalgic
because it's just there's no yeah you
don't see anything pulls the right horny
strings yeah yeah it really does I saw
one where they were showing they were
like showing dong on it it was um that
takes the joy away that kid it was just
weird because I'm just imagining the
whole production yeah because I know
like maybe they're gonna usually there's
this hot or the sock yeah
covered or whatever but I was like all
right he's just showing his weiner was
Eric
um
the hell is his name he was the
boyfriend on Six Feet Under oh Eric
Balfour yeah yeah who's very weird
looking people he's a big right it
wasn't that big for to be in the movie
the way it was but his ass was really
good he was like really it was like he
was hot I was definitely like looking
I'm like what's he look like now oh he
aged well okay
married with kids that's cute
that's weird but he's in odd he's an odd
looking man oh this dude oh yeah yeah I
remember him he always looks he looks
like he'd be in a boy band or something
yeah you know
um like One Direction like Zayn he also
kind of looks like um like one of the
vegetables from VeggieTales too he was
very his head's very like wait what's
veggies remember Veggie Tales are like
Christian cartoon yeah they use
vegetables look up Veggie Tales show her
Veggie Tales and you'll see what I'm
saying one of our professors looked like
the broccoli
like a veggie down
oh my God you look like the zucchini
yeah the zucchini or the Cucumbers or
what I'm saying the asparagus looked
like my professor in college wait I want
to ask you
um do you feel ugly when you go to Korea
do I feel ugly
um because I was just talking to David
so yeah yeah I had dinner with him yeah
yeah and he was like man he's like
when I go to Korea I never feel uglier I
feel like everyone is really well put
together over there there's just so many
you know skin wellness places like like
a McDonald's on every corner you just go
in and they got a chart and you can it's
like casual you go in there and get
BOTOX like on a Tuesday or something you
know and and they're really well put
together but I don't really like the
look of the typical Korean beauty look
like even if you follow like a hot
Korean girl they don't do enough
ketamine yeah no I like them a little
rough
up bags on their eyes oh no not
something a lot of the girls like if you
even if you look at their Instagram
they're like the filters they use are
like super pale it's quite kind of
cartoony a little bit I just don't like
the look you know like when I go there I
usually tend to lean towards girls that
kind of look like they're Asian girls in
L.A yeah you know what I mean like like
their hair is blonde they got hoop
earrings yeah yeah ABG eyelashes I love
ABG I know that's that's the look I love
Asian baby girl it's kind of chola-ish
yeah Jason but they have to have very
specific tattoo placements a lot of
times like on the thigh or it's a very
eye tattoos have thrown on me so hard
contacts right like contact lenses
sometimes but those are like the older
ABG girls listen blonde Asians you got
to be honest slightly cross-eyed number
one I love Mia Blondie
any gender it's what's up you know like
when I do my party I threw a West Coast
themed party in Korea it was called la
la la la la la la and then it attracted
all the like Koreans that love like West
Coast there's all these blonde
Asians with LA hats and like tube tops
you know I love that like it was lit no
um yeah it was fun that's like Filipinos
we there's a term called jejemon yeah
and jejimon is like our version of that
they're very just like the hip-hop kids
but they wear like the bandana so they
they try to like follow copy like the
Western night their westernized idea of
like hip-hop but it's um it's considered
like not cool back home because they say
like oh you're so judge it which is like
you know kind of like not but I think
it's kind of this cool little culture of
their own I feel like internationally
people love West Coast more than east
coast culture I think so I feel like
more people are like into park and more
than like biggies there's more murals of
like Pock and like Germany and like
across Asia you know I mean like the
West Coast won the beef internationally
you know what it is
East Coast loves the East Coast East
Coast but can I just say it right
because I'm East Coast but I'm so
obsessed with that I love living here
now
um so when I came from the Philippines
for the first time I didn't know the
difference between Kansas or L.A I just
thought America was America so I I can
firmly say that I didn't know that there
was an East Coast West Coast I just
thought it was America and then hip-hop
and then POC and then biggie I didn't
know that there was a whole Beast didn't
understand that whole you're just like
no it's just America did you see the
theory that
um Tupac is alive and living on a
reservation in New Mexico now they moved
it to New Mexico there's always
sightings
New Zealand I lived in New Mexico for
seven years like
you're there to you gotta go on a hike
or something you can't just like hide
away like why would he just would not
have a life he would just be like in
what I feel like if Tupac was in New
Mexico you'd have known by now because
you have so many friends that still live
there but New Mexico is not a bad like
that theory could check out you know
like that that'd be a good place to hide
out you know I mean like I'm not gonna
see him in K-Town you know
but it's like okay so it's I lived in
Santa Fe for seven years it's like
there's a lot of like desert it's just
what is he living in like a a like a
Airstream
maybe and just that his whole life is
just like hiding away he had like a
poncho on she would live like somewhere
far away right he would be on an island
probably live out like and also he's a
performer he likes to be out he likes to
be like he's gonna be just hidden away
for the rest of his life yeah yeah like
he's in I don't know he I I think he's
gonna like one of them like Cleveland
joints for Chappelle or something you
know
camp like one of those camps he's
actually Matt Rafe he just got surgery
he's hiding under Matt Wright's face
ever right there
listen when you got Star Quality you got
star quality
I always wanted to pull white
the only way no
never have that alternate dream that you
keep in you know like the recesses of
your mind just in case goes wrong
like what is that thing where you're
like okay if doesn't work out I'm
just gonna do this and be okay with it
that shit's scary now honestly because
people get canceled and you can't make
money no more so I think about that
because I'm like not rich enough to get
canceled yet yeah I know I can't wait to
get the answer
that's horrifying to think about like I
dead ass think about this all the time
because I'm like I'm looking at my
finances like what if I did get canceled
right now where what bracket am I you
know like how glad you're so correct
though because like wouldn't you say
that even friends of ours where like we
they started off at a certain level and
then they start to rise and you're just
holding your breath for them you're like
it's gonna I mean it's gonna happen
everyone is going to get canceled to
some degree
I don't think I'm not afraid of
canceling anymore because I really have
only seen careers grow you're not wrong
I I think your career getting canceled
yeah I think your career starts at a
canceling
then you blow up you think you're blown
up until that cancel happens and it
depends what you're canceled for like
like who's been canceled that's really
canceled Harvey Weinstein print these in
prison if he was free he'd be we'd have
some new Hollywood stars Sandra Bullock
wouldn't be playing such young
characters anymore would she
we have some young hotties coming in you
still have to get some good momentum to
get canceled I didn't make a comeback
yes yes can I say something about the
Harvey Lansing girls too we used to play
the Harvey Weinstein game I might have
told you guys this already but
where if there's like an actress that's
in a lot of stuff but she's like not hot
she's like you're like kind of surprised
that she's playing like all these really
like hot rolls hot girls if you we would
Google image her and Harvey Weinstein
and Harvey's there's always pictures of
Harvard oh my God she was a harvey
placement she planted her he has a bunch
of pictures probably right yeah just in
Google Images it's basically everyone
he was running he was running the ship
yeah
um yes okay so Kevin Spacey did get
fully canceled
I don't know what his deal he's not
really canceled but he's not out there
like that but he's so weird and strange
that he he still Peaks everyone's
interest so I think that child stars a
little bit you're like all right yeah
shy is in the in the bracket of people
who get canceled and it kind of
them up personally like mentally you
know like Chris Brown it didn't really
him up he's just continuing he's
dancing still the same he's got better
at dancing
his meet and greet pictures are the
funniest thing I've ever seen he's just
like groping the girl the girls are like
riding pictures Chris Brown's is
funny because he always shares like his
crib like his interior design is so
trash like money cannot like money
cannot buy you taste like whatsoever he
just is he all proud of it his place is
crazy like crazy inside I want to see
like a wild ass architectural digest
episode of his is this like insane
murals everywhere
yeah you're not going to get canceled
for this level of things like these are
like
like and Cosby's going on tour again
yeah
there's no way Cosby's going on yeah he
is is he really yeah
I'm not gonna lie I'd like to attend
that me too if we're gonna
you know what he's gonna talk about do
we have booed like or you know I'm
trying you know people are probably
gonna go in there protest all types of
yeah but I'm guessing there are
people so I mean the older generation
who probably still love him who are not
so
um kind of Switched on about like what
cancel means cancellation they're
probably just like Cosby what's happened
this is so great people don't know some
people don't know it's weird you think
everyone knows all these things I'm
telling you he'd kill it in the
Philippines
well yeah I mean well people probably
don't care as much over there well it's
not even if they don't care they
probably are not it's not in their news
cycle as much that he was even canceled
well also his fan like the age bracket
of his fans are like too old to protest
you know like protesting takes a lot of
energy outside of his house it's a
little smaller than I thought it would
be oh yeah
Sonic
that is that is trash
also but like look at the cows where's
that couch from that's crazy did he take
it from before his uh this is bad it's
like an 18 year old school
yeah this is like an 18 year old skater
who just signed like his first big deal
in his life I think it's a small house
I've seen like a Brazzers set better
than this like for real this is
wild
oh my gosh this is pretty this is I feel
like this is what my place would look
like if I let Todd really maybe
I hate the tiles of that bathroom that
interior of this bathroom what is going
on man disgusting
disgusting I'm so mad
it doesn't look like a terrible come on
I got Phillip Hughes bro you're you're
way richer you got the Philippi light
bulbs the weakest settings
I do like how the lights look though
and that's the oh that's the house okay
it doesn't look small I only saw a
little corner of it
yeah no I mean um yeah like there's just
I feel like that's the biggest thing
when people get canceled like it does
mess with you permanently I feel
yeah you know like you're not the same
but I love what Annie always says she's
like cancel this a state of mind like it
really if you can switch like how you
think about it like what are you
canceled for are you did you like are a
bunch of H's
pose like what what would you get
canceled like if you're getting canceled
for like you said something and it was
taken out of context or but that's even
yes you have to do the whole
apology tour for some you're
probably not even sorry for but it's
like you have the pressures of deals or
people you know like yeah some of the
things like the lizzo canceling is a
little wild to me because I'm like I
need a little bit more backstory not to
me that's that's kind of messed up you
know like people were waiting on her to
up the people were really waiting
on lizzo but is it on lizzo for being
like I create a safe space you know what
I mean like is it kind of like you can't
use the language of the cancellers I
kind of hate that too it's like well you
can't roast the people you work with you
should be allowed the class by the way
out of the people you work with eat
like Ellen like I don't I think Ellen
shouldn't have been canceled I think she
should have whatever like what she's
watching she took care of so many people
in her audience she was the first slap a
banana out of a PA's hand like come on
dude she was the first like lesbian open
lesbian on TV like she did it is
interesting and she seems like maybe
she's a little rough but oh well also
it's like toxic work environment I
understand it to a degree but like that
is there's so that word toxic in general
so overused I think work environments
should be done they should be talking
like in my area it is that's it's toxic
that's how they became the I feel the
same way prospering country yeah how
many men I just feel like okay with the
lizard the banana part of the lizzo
thing from what I understand is like
they went to the strip club the
performer puts the puts the banana
inside herself and then makes someone
eat it and then lizzo was like got one
of her dancers to eat it and was like
you have to eat it or off the tour which
sounds like she's kidding so funny
though and also you're not really going
to be fired from the tour you know what
it reminds me what your outward friends
think about like the that I've done
at strip clubs like amongst my friends I
brought my own banana
[Laughter]
it's like we're wiling out like we are
not we are just having a good time
there's a rapport right like when you
read that in a document like written out
that way it's like of course that seems
up but like if you were there if
any of those people were there they
would be like oh you know what it is
it's like the roasts hit harder when
it's coming from someone you don't
respect you know like you know what I
mean just because she was bigger and she
said this said that joke to her yeah
you're like this really like it
just hits it probably just stung it
actually it hurts more you know what I
mean like when I got a homie who like
doesn't have his life together and tries
to give me advice on my career I'm like
oh my God I get hot I get mad as hell
like are you serious right now
and open my girl that gives me notes on
his I'm gonna back away from it that's
right the audacity like that's I think
that's kind of the situation that may be
that may be it that's it yeah I recently
found out
for like two years for some like
streaming service that I used for 30
seconds and I'm like where I needed
rocket money like what was I thinking
I think I'm still paying for like an
insect identifier
of course you are well you might need
that
you're like do I date it is it a pet do
I kill it but if your subscriptions are
draining your wallet like you're not
alone the average person has around 12
paid subscriptions and they might not
even remember subscribing to half of
those and if you have no idea just how
much you're spending each month you need
rocket money it's a great app that
tracks all of your expenses so you know
exactly where your money is going rocket
money is a personal finance app that
finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place it's crazy they can even help you
like negotiate your bills to be lower by
up to 20 all you have to do is take a
picture of your bill and Rocket money
will just handle it and they can also
recommend custom budgets for you no it's
like having your own little Jewish
grandfather in an app they look at your
past spending and they're like hey maybe
ease up on this
I got a lot of apps it's embarrassing
I've subscribed to everything that's
ever been offered to anything I believe
you and they make it so difficult to
find the cancel button I don't know how
but somehow I've I email subscribe to
New Jersey
state of New Jersey the state of New
Jersey
stop wasting money on things you don't
use cancel your unwanted subscriptions
and manage your money the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
that's rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday guys we're
busy not only are we busy but some of us
can't be trusted to cook for others okay
that is fine I would like I would like
if I ever get at your house again it's
Gotta Be factor I need them to portion
it out I want to make sure nothing's
poisoned or anything factor is America's
number one ready to eat meal kit can
help you fuel up fast with Chef prepared
dietitian approved Ready-to-Eat meals
delivered straight to your door okay
honestly
cooking portioning I don't I can't like
I'm a busy woman I'm on the go and
Factor meals are so delicious and
they're healthy and they make things so
easy and you can choose from over 34
weekly flavor packed dietitian approved
meals ready to eat in two minutes and
level up with Gourmet plus options
prepare to Perfection by chefs and ready
to eat in record time which is very
important to me treat yourself to
upscale meals with premium ingredients
like broccolini leeks truffle butter and
asparagus and also if you're looking for
like a calorie conscious option ahead of
a busy season try delicious dietitian
approved calorie smart meals with around
or less than 550 calories per second I
tried to have the way the the the scale
to weigh out my food I'm it's just not
for me it's not going to happen so I
can't personally count my own macros
that is something I will never do in
this lifetime not it's not worth my time
it's not worth my life and so Factor
doing it for me is what's up head to
factormeels.com trash50 and use code
trash50 to get 50 off that's code
trash50 at factormeels.com trash50 to
get 50 off price picks is the most fun
I've had
Sports gambling
well knowledge listen no I'm sorry when
I when people talk about sports my eyes
would glaze over I was like why are we
doing this what's going on when I found
out there could be money involved I am
all ears I'm on the edge of my seat and
yeah Khalil and I are now experts on
Sports do you want to use any sports
questions anyone yeah any sports
questions do you have any sports
questions for us
um well do you know Patrick Mahomes and
how he
can you say his name again Patrick
Mahoney
[Laughter]
um he's our favorite player no but I
honestly since we've been sponsored by
prize picks I haven't seen you without a
smile on your face I mean she's won like
25 times the money guys I'm freaking do
you understand
between rocket money on this I'm loading
quick withdrawals
um easy gameplay and an enormous
selection of players and Stat types are
what make price picks the number one
daily fantasy sports app every day baby
this week on price picks I know Annie is
selecting saquan Barkley for more than
60 yards and Patrick right our boy
Patrick for more than two pounds oh yeah
and Aaron Rodgers for more than three
passing touchdowns right uh-huh also one
thing that I do really love about prize
picks is that they now offer Apple pay
for quick and easy deposits into your
account for this football season and you
can go to prize picks.com trash Tuesday
and use code trash Tuesday for a first
deposit match up to 100 all lower case
that's prizepix.com trash Tuesday and
use code trash Tuesday for a first
deposit match up to 100 prize picks
daily fantasy sports Made Easy Annie
what about your boy Odell Beckham Jr oh
I love y'all
um
I think he's going to go for more than
50 yards and and Josh Allen for more
than two passing touchdowns I think
that's a really good prediction good on
you I think you're gonna win 25 times
the money you put in yeah and guys you
know what we just gave you a hundred
dollars yeah like take this to your guy
by the way if you want to connect with
your boyfriend during football season
give him this code and he's gonna go
down on you for a long time he's gonna
go touchdown on you
wait I have a really um important
question for you guys okay since we have
a male guest today should men tell you
there is a potential that their dick
might go soft let's say they have
erectile dysfunction should they tell
that to you up front or just take the
risk and no hell no I'm rolling dice
every time
let's go you know I mean and also
there's also you know dudes if that
happens you got to be prepared you know
I mean with a Cialis and there's so many
things on the market oh yeah like I'm on
the like after Dave going back to the
crib I'm just
[Laughter]
smooth as hell just popping it you know
just enabling out of my wallet bam you
know I wonder how I would feel though if
some guy was like hey just as a heads up
like this thing happens to me once in a
while I don't want you to take it
personally well the funniest is when
they're like this never happens they're
like that's more insulting
Consulting and I don't believe you but
also no I always just go I'm too hot
what I think is all that matters though
you mean like right before he's about to
have sex like you guys yeah just be like
you know if he's concerned I don't need
to hear if my might go soft once in
a while but it's not UK even during the
dinner date it's like it's not let's not
jump the gun buddy
speaking of mashed potatoes
no no I think that's whack first of all
it doesn't feel like you're spontaneous
right you know what I mean that sounds
whack yeah yeah because I I don't think
that I would love it actually but there
is something to be said I know it's not
my fault but I do take it personally
when they go soft on me and I really
like in the you know now I'm like okay
it's definitely not my fault but there
are times where I'm like like do
you ever try yelling at them just get it
hard
no but I I do feel that like especially
when a guy is like oh I just can't come
I'm like oh not being overcome so
annoying like I know and and now there's
a whole movement of like not chasing the
calm you're supposed to just like enjoy
the sex well that's different from Ed
and coming right right so yeah I mean
before is like Ed goes like the dude if
that happens like he just has to be
prepared yeah what is he doing yeah
and then if you tell me now it's on me
to like worry about I'm like okay but
here hear me out okay what if it's a
situation where is this something that's
happened to you no no she's asking for
specific advice yeah yeah yeah no like
what if he was wearing a blue shirt
okay so what if he there are some
counter indications
um with his medications that doesn't
allow him to pop see out sorry guys if
you're meant to listen mentally ill I'm
done I've done that I'm out of that
phase of my life what do you mean Annie
what is this guy through Sunday
popping the pill now I've got to know
about his other kids
he's crying
it's not the erectile dysfunction has
nothing to do with you it's I'm just
really depressed and cry a lot yeah yeah
it's like uh maybe you need to like
handle stuff inside yourself maybe
you're not ready to have sex with me no
but see I warn guys up front I'm like
hey sometimes I explode in tears after
sex or after I come like don't be
freaked out it has nothing it's not
because that would freaked me out okay
to be honest if I tell you that up front
or after
um I mean both like that's that's like
heavy you know I mean that what what
would you say what would you tell people
okay this is how I say it like but I
don't say it like just so you know she's
like I'm a squirter but out of here
a top scorer yeah no usually it will um
come up organically and just like when
I'm talking to someone just be like oh
this like weird thing happens to me and
I cry when I come and I can't control
like the tears and I'm actually and I
just say it like that and
I'm a girl I Cry Sometimes no but I go
into I'll usually be like oh there's
this article about blah blah blah blah
and I explain that it happens yes I do
because it's scary if a girl
just burst out crying uh I mean I'd
rather it surprise me
I I would you know it's it's fine and I
think your ego would probably like it a
little you're like this says
here's yeah but then there's that study
that alleges that men get turned off
when they see girls cry I have always
had boyfriends like you're so hot when
you cry they like love when I think
that's why they yell at me so much but
what do you think what are your thoughts
on that there's a study that says like
men when they um how did they do the
test Annie was it with like a Ascent of
like tears or something like that but it
was like a legitimate task and when they
when they were
um exposed to like the tears of a woman
they became like oh just in general yeah
not in not in the sack or anything just
when you're out and about and they start
crying less sexually aroused by women
that um are crying yeah I mean I don't I
don't know like I'm not in you know I'm
not looking to get aroused or anything
in those moments but I got the farmer's
market yeah I know right
women's tears dampened sexual desire in
men I hate this I think this is false I
could I know I could see this happening
for sure you know like it's just like
it's like what I was just saying it's
like I I don't want like just like guys
crying all the time it's like you guys
don't want just like the crying girl
you're like oh I gotta like I'm gonna be
responsible for this person's mood or
whatever I don't know okay so what
you're telling me is if a girl were to
burst into tears after coming you would
rather it be a surprise no I'd rather
they cry then though you know than like
any other moment during the day like
during the dinner it's like yeah you're
definitely not getting any that night I
think you know you gotta you gotta
console her you gotta you know you're
having a consoling night you're gonna
have a talk you're gonna have a long
time
um I yeah I don't know I don't whatever
I mean that's a condition that's fine I
don't even know about this is the new
thing that you know it's it's cool get
your cry on I think it's called like oh
what's this oh my gosh
shout out Urban Dictionary what's
console
comfort someone at a time of grief or
disappointment with your penis that's
how I imagined it to be by the way I
really hate myself when I find myself
searching for things on Urban Dictionary
there was a time where I didn't need to
do that
oh that was down with it I knew
everything you know and now we're at
that age we're like oh Cog song
you gotta see how it's used in a
sentence and everything uh
but you can't trust it either it's all a
lot of it's just yeah okay so
follow-up question to that if a woman
has a hard time like typically orgasming
is it something that she should discuss
with you just be like yeah like it
really it's hard for me to come so like
don't even try or not don't even try but
just like don't worry about it if I
don't
or are you just I've heard that a lot uh
like you're saying from girls yeah from
girls yeah I've heard that like you know
it's it's all right just you finish
yeah yeah so I don't mind if I do no no
no no but like already did
good timing
um yeah I've I've heard that you know
several times I guess from girls that's
just I don't know what what's your
question yeah that is it's like you know
is it weird for a guy to hear that like
a French is like hey like it you could
go like listen after the entire Sade
album's gone through you're like all
right I want you to give yourself a
break all over Sade albums
I don't know but there was a guy that
was like he's like I eat out to an
entire album it's not so funny but he
still didn't what I didn't come no it
wasn't so terrible no no he was very
good I would be about to come and then I
yeah it's exhausting at that point
though because you're like damn am I is
she is this her or am I here
it'd be so funny because I hooked up
with him for a while and he would be
like
you could come over and he his ego was
so attached to making me come so he
would just like go for all like as long
as he had to yeah at some point the
goes dead though he said it's like
not as far as like me yeah I always find
the pretending to orgasm like such an
interesting thing oh my God dudes don't
do that no no no dudes do that oh my God
you're so wrong you're so wrong with
someone talking about this yes okay so a
really close friend of mine who is
happens to be a dude just admitted to me
that he has faked in the last couple of
years 50 of his orgasms that's crazy
like my body xinjiang and I just kind of
want to like you know want to give him a
win I'm not even a good enough actor for
that yeah I mean I don't think I
could pull it off I don't think I could
either and it's it's actually very
embarrassing like the idea of getting
caught lying about orgasming to me is
like way worse than just being like
high five we tried and I don't want no
follow-up like where where's the cup
yeah
you can just like pull the condom off
and throw it out before anyone sees it
oh that is or if you're busting inside
then you can say you've busted yeah but
girls always know when it drips out
if you're coming inside someone yeah
they're like you came inside me I need
yeah like you gotta send me 50 bucks but
he's like I didn't actually well I know
let me ask you how much can you feel
someone coming in not zero at all
nothing at all we don't feel anything
no no no no I know the movement of the
penis as it's coming so there's like you
know the body looks a little different
so I can know when they're coming but
the actual squirting into the back of me
I don't feel it do you I don't think so
yeah
because we're the ones selling it like
yeah I'm coming in you do you feel the
stream do you feel the stream it's warm
it's warm no I'm telling you guys
it's just no way that
biologically we would be built to have
that many nerves up there because it
does it's not conducive to like like to
hurt internally like so it doesn't hurt
no I'm just saying like I think that
don't you feel the warm squirts I would
feel like
I'm gonna test this out I have to now
you messed me up because now I don't
believe this girl is like I feel it you
know
you lying you don't feel
that's why it's good when they're coming
to you it does really you know I like my
special sauce I like to get comment on
my you do strawberry shortcakes
yeah that's Annie's favorite okay but
that's interesting you're saying you
know there's nothing I have never in my
life right am I crazy about us it's warm
and then you plop it out you plop it out
you have to go to the bathroom do the
plot but the actual propulsion of the
thing coming out I don't feel I feel
like maybe some people feel that some
people don't I mean you're the type to
cry during sex so maybe that explains
maybe that explains the numbness
oh my God you have an empathic um
it feels at all I can feel when you get
coming
wait when I'm coming in a different High
Town
what key going oh my God someone just
came in
it's always at a weird time you're
always somewhere I'm like is she in the
Philippines what hours we might have to
cut all of this out but like I have I
have a real sickness with like OG recipe
like original recipe like
I have to tell a guy up front
no matter what I say during sex you have
to pull out
because what I say during sex is
criminal this information I want Jiu
Jitsu pull you and say like I want
your baby with those shoulders
too I know but that's why I have to give
the you pull them under the refrigerator
you're like get my crisper
but this is like an insane thing I do so
I have to tell them up front like you
cannot listen to me you have to promise
me you have to be the only adult yeah
well I I could see yeah I mean because
when you're in the mood in the zone yeah
I mean I could see that was just part of
the demonstration of sorts
what lizzo did to you yeah I'm not doing
anything
we have a segment called bananas
oh re-up on potassium
um sicknesses do you have potassium what
do you need
um no but yeah yeah that whole thing of
like pull out because like at that point
it's like a
test or something you know well like
what happens to me is that it feels so
biologically natural for someone to do
like the mess that's coming after this
is such a nightmare morning after pills
I'm not thinking straight I'm so horny
in that moment I'm like I don't give a
like I just want could I ask you
guys something like what has been some
what has been some of the protocols of
somebody
coming on you and then the cleanup
afterwards that's a really great
question because I I've always I'm
always a little insecure about my
cleanup methods like especially when I'm
like hey hold up and I'd like run I just
feel goofy as hell totally now yourself
yeah I'm holding or you know I'm like
you know well you got a little drip you
have to deal with it yourself or like
grabbing them uh you know a wet towel
and all that like recently I like
grabbed a
um like a tissue paper and I wedded a
towel and I wiped her with the wet I had
it all oh my gosh yeah the full service
it just looked kind of wagged to her
I'll tell you what I was like this
dude's doing too much like you know what
I mean I can tell you why that was a
grave mistake I don't I I felt it was a
great mistake
well it's not that it's
I think for me because I have a lot of
like sensory aversions the idea of
tissue and wet tissue the away it's
like yeah and plus water and are
kind of like oil and water tissue what
do you mean no tissue no towel tissues
are the worst and that's like it gets
stuck on you like a shaving accident
a little shaving paper towels though
paper towel a little bit better off low
rough rough low roots are we in a
kitchen like what's going on
the sweetest thing you can do honestly
if if a microwave is at your disposal
come on
oh gosh no kalila you princess
I want a warm towel I will remember
we're not in first class right you're
not getting a warm towel our go-to has
been the paper towel it's it depends
again what brand I kind of like that I
imagine you're like in Chris Brown's
house with just like a roll of paper
towel next to your bed no no I wouldn't
you see like I still keep it in my you
know the paper towel holder rod thing so
I I go to the kitchen you okay but
kitchen's close to my bedroom yeah you
know if it wasn't then I would probably
I said you grab a t-shirt just grab the
T-shirt t-shirt's okay sure but I love
like someone who has ran the towel under
hot water and then done this video so
I've never I've never seen you as this
high maintenance
I I like I want it steamed I want a
fresh steamed towel I'm just saying
bonus points if you do that but spray a
little like a little lavender on it you
even did the whole ring the water out
you have to yeah
no excess water and everything any bonus
points if you put in a microwave for 10
seconds then it's like oh there's no way
anyone someone did that for you full
service Spa yeah you know like when you
go to those Asian like massage parlors
and they have every one of those rooms
has a rice cooker when I go down you
know why parlor they better use one of
those when they wipe their off me
well all of them have a rice cooker in
the room because that's where they heat
the towel I think next to your bed
should be a rice cooker
just for those situations if you don't
want to do it in a microwave then have a
rice cooker by your bed all right how
about a dude who goes and washes himself
off first that's he's done that he's out
of here he's out yeah he's so
rude okay you know what I'll take let me
tell you what I'll take I'll take a guy
going to the sink to wash himself off
while he does it gets a hand towel
washer throws the hand towel at me I'll
take that
I'll take it it's a mutual as he's
watching he throws me around I'd like to
be I like Aftercare is very important
for me I like well you're crying and
you're weeping so yes no it's a whole
thing it's like I like to shower with
them I want yeah of course you know yes
I love being scrubbed down all the way
after you know I'm with you with a
shower afterwards yeah because the
initial wipe down that's why I
appreciate that you came in with the
towel and with the tissue where you did
it I feel like but I think that's just
the just a preliminary getting it so it
doesn't drip onto the mattress I try not
to do the shower because I feel like
girl enjoys their solo shower you know
what I mean like get your I am never
ever wanting to be alone oh you don't
want the solo shower okay I'm already
up multiple times I never but I
just personally never wanna
um I after after especially when I was
like
having like well
would I want to shower the one well this
is why like lesbians are so great
because the Aftercare of lesbian sex or
with a girl is just Superior to all cry
together
wait what was the what was the um what's
the Bravo show where was the gay guys in
the house together oh God the night yeah
what was it called that's bass show yeah
and then they did on SNL they did the
lesbian version it was just like women
like these like like Butch women like in
bed together I see you
[Laughter]
that's the funniest thing wait has
someone ever washed you in the shower
like have you ever been like washed
washed I've been washed it's so intimate
yeah here's my thing so one time I asked
uh we all started crying no but I had
asked a boy to basically recreate a big
drama of mine when I was 16 there was a
30 year old guy who kind of held me like
hostage for the night like he wouldn't
give me a ride home from Reseda because
he was like you have to me and
um I was 16 he was 30. he took me to
Claim Jumper I thought I was like oh wow
this is great but I thought we were just
gonna go back home but he didn't he took
me to his home and he was like I'm not
giving you a ride home tonight and he
was
we had sex but he was so brutal with me
and really just a very negative sexual
experience so I look at Julian he's
welcome again to Josh Tuesday
like a queen though that those Those
portions are used he said he took you to
Claim Jumper and then he claimed at you
he claimed company for sure he jumped me
yeah no but when I drive past a Claim
Jumper in Burbank I think that's like
the only like the last one left like I
do like I glitch out a little bit
because oh I hate the little PTSD glitch
I luckily they're getting discontinued
so you'll be fine once that last one
gets out of here but um I had a guy I
had asked him to recreate that whole
night because yeah like take back the
night kind of thing yeah but so he did
like he did everything he beat me up he
pissed on my hair on my face like
everything everything brutalized but
then afterwards
[Music]
I don't care
and he was very like are you sure and I
was like keep going I keep going
and then afterwards he gave me a
spa-like treatment like the hair
conditioning the everything he put a
stake on your uh cucumbers and honestly
it changed me a little bit where I was
like oh I think this was my Take Back
the Night moment mad people used to get
bathed like a lot more back in the day
all those kings and queens yeah that
that's that looks always nice in like
Game of Thrones or something you know
but those are like but what about like
the regulars like do they get like
bathed no
I don't I mean honestly but back back
then it probably felt so much better too
because it was way more rough yeah you
know like just getting through life and
then you get bathed at the end of the
day um that sounds amazing yeah well
you're still you're upset about this I
don't like that he beat you he didn't
beat me so hard that he like any
permanent injury like you know there was
like there there was some like there was
aggressive yeah and um but it I don't
know it I felt like it was under my
control still right because I had the
safe word all of these things were and
genuinely I probably traumatized the
poor guy he's probably like what the
did I just do you know well the
worst is when you kind of get a little
like you're like you could be a little
rough and then they get real you're like
all right relax
but a little what the is going on
like how are you waiting for this that's
what all these things are tricky you
gotta feel it out and then guys don't
know how to pull hair properly it's like
you gotta get it at the beach yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
you hear the proper way once and you
never go back get in there you know you
get all in there
yeah Katie you Katie is
vibing with our combo you know another
thing though that you know just talking
about like washing your dick and stuff
like to like watch clean it up and stuff
I always really annoyed that the sink is
just not at the right length like you
gotta like it's a berry yeah Tippy Toe
to throw your balls and dick on the top
of the it's like if they just made a
slight adjustment of a few inches you
know you got to like Drag The Squatty
Potty over and like stand on it you
gotta like straddle the thing I do I
will tell you though that things are
probably built better for you and more
convenient for you than us like holy
gymnastics we have to do to even
like for instance if it's like a last
minute hookup hard it is to wash a
like on the go have you ever stood on
the top of a sink all the time all
because I'm trying to get like front to
back access so the mirror is on my back
and I've hopped up backwards onto the
thing yeah and then I'll wash this way
so having uh sync sex memories oh really
tell me oh I used to hook up with this
guy I worked at one bar and he worked at
another and we would like meet up and
hook up in the bathroom and Santa Fe I'm
going to Santa Fe maybe I'll do my
bathrooms I banged in tour you have to
do bathrooms you banged in that's gonna
be sad though because you know when you
go back to like a town you lived in and
it's like things just inevitably had
changed I haven't lived there since I
was you know wait can you do a tick tock
series of this yeah but just explain you
don't even have to be super graphic
about it just be like you know walking
through the bathroom like rate it from
like a one to ten oh it was so cute I
hope it's still the way it was
but if there's like no bathroom there
anymore but what were you saying oh
another wash question
um if how often do you wash your ass in
hopes that you will get your ass eaten
on that all the time my ass so is that
like protocol anyway you've always been
a wash your ass so while you're watching
I don't soak my vagina at all like I
never do because it I just feel like
everything smells better when my pH kind
of just does its own thing so I I but I
soap the out of my ass like but I
always do because I like um my preferred
entry of Choice by a man is if he were
to flip me over and go ask first like to
eat me out like eating me out from the
back that way is like the hottest thing
ever
so there's times that Esther would have
vetoed this entire discussion I'm just
trying to think of what song lyric I
want to like
punctuate your story but I always I like
a lot of ass play I'm thinking of
Peaches I have two activities like you
want to make them basketball is very
important to me I washed my dick like
right before like the show that's so
sweet oh my God
honored uh yeah just in case I have to
whip it out no no uh so like before a
girl was coming over I was like just in
a hurry so I washed my dick and that's
so polite thank you for that no but it
was like like way too close to when we
got it's always Tuesday so she almost
like she's she's like did you just wash
your dick she smelled the soap and
everything I was kind of embarrassed
that I actually it's better I think it's
better to put the effort in I think so
too but also
um when I really like someone I really
don't care
um yeah like the condition of it if
we're if we're on we're on but I can't
appreciate it up I'm coming to hook up
with you if you wash your dick yeah but
you know what I really you know I've
talked about this so much and I just
have yet to implement this is I don't
know how to have
spontaneous sex unwashed like if you're
just like oh let's go I have to
find a bathroom and it's got to be this
whole thing and I don't know why I can't
just like let go and trust that my
partner is okay with it
I know I know I I used to be a lot more
adventurous and I just I'm kind of
ashamed of myself that I I do wash my
dick pretty frequently yeah you know
what I mean I wish I was just more like
going to the bathroom let's get it on
you know like I've had I used like I
remember having sex in in an office I
worked at Farmers Insurance Farmers
Insurance yeah I worked that I worked at
a farmer's insurance and like what did
you do there like a customer service
worked under like a broker or whatever
Insurance she was a broker
and then yeah
um
how did you meet her what was like she
was like a girl I was dating we worked
at the same place so it's so fun wait
workplace sex is so hot I've never
experienced that was the only time I did
it
was um was cool and then she even like
we had a whole thing she like tighter my
hands on his office chair things like
this I put like a thing over it was
that's three hours yeah I know but we
were sure like they were gone for a
while oh so it was after hours not like
no no it was during it was during nah
they didn't have cameras this is a while
ago okay no I mean I'm sure they had
cameras just resurface this now nah it
was like a janky like this is how you
get canceled okay
they find your tapes yeah not Farmers
Insurance uh Prudential whatever no
um yeah but that was like the one time
that was like a crazy place but I'm not
that adventurous to I you know it's sad
to say yeah actually the ladies are
watching this I am adventurous now yeah
he's so adventurous you guys I bet I I
think that
sex in public is the the thrill of it is
not the actual sex itself right it's
just this idea of like people could hear
you yeah and find out but I don't find
that
um pleasurable sex like I can't imagine
having sex with a guy like on a plane
say for instance I'm coming like you who
comes from like Mile High
oh Annie
Annie's been fingered on a plane I
didn't come though I wasn't we didn't
but we just it was a hardcore make out
Sash and fingering yeah that sounds
pretty hot though he passed away died he
died he died and we found out on the
show because we try to search him he was
so such a hilarious character that guy
yeah she had just met him at the gate
previous right right in that way I'd
miss my flight so we went to the we
journeyed to our next flight together
and he got our seats together and well
you might be the only one he's ever
fingered in his life before he went out
he was in a Sugar Ray cover band so
you had a lot of miles
um he was so hot he was extremely hot
like if I'm getting freaky on the couch
with a partner then I I I'm like let's
let's go to the bedroom yeah yeah is
that cool
I think we just like grew up yeah you
said so funny I used to be so just get a
headboard in an expensive mattress just
so my knees could get bruised over here
right right I chose you I used to have
like
a fantasy of this was when I was like
still like repressed but I was very
high schooly in my head so I wanted to
like and make out in high school
anyways so it would always be like I
liked on couches and in my
fantasy it'd always be like we met at
like a party he went to a different
School than me like in my head I'm like
creating all this and that is like
Middle School put on some Sublime let's
go that honestly I that is to recreate
something of your childhood is so like
dry humping dry humping is the best it's
so underrated bring it back but you'll
never get the same dry hump that we used
to get back it was so excited if you
edge enough though
I think you can I feel like it's never
this like it's not you know that that
hot summer you know fling you how you're
gonna burn a car all that you never it's
never the same like I remember it being
the best like back in the day I'm like I
never got it back Todd and I were
talking about we're like oh my God car
sex remember car sex it's like
everything was it was so because you
like you had parent like you couldn't
in regular places you would and
even when you get like in your 20s you
have roommates and stuff so it's like
you're you know you're just
where you can but it's like now
that you're a grown-up it's like yeah I
have a nice bed yeah nothing is really
going to match the feeling of making out
with John Lynn in his car to Brian
McKnight's anytime you know what I mean
late at night yeah and I was in
my Ford Focus like that that was
amazing you know and even in my like
like shitty apartment yeah approaches
everywhere yeah bad girls waking up to
bed bug bites you know what I mean like
it was and it was still hot you know air
mattresses I banged on a lot of waterbed
water badass my Virginia on a water bed
yeah I don't think I've ever had sex on
a water bed I don't I don't know if I
could even count it it was it was pretty
wild
we were floating
[Laughter]
yeah but that's another adventurous
thing that doesn't work like I remember
being younger and in a pool with a boy
and being like put it in brilliant and
it's horrible yeah
don't do it get a UTI no thank you guys
right right
um but I recently just found out
um that silverback gorillas have the
tiniest penises did you know this like
Randy like three centimeters three
inches
my dog has the smallest penis of
anything I've ever seen in my life but
I'm just saying like in primates and how
we evolved why do you think there was
the need for the human to then grow a
larger penis so they do penetrate their
mate with that thing yeah but look at
that big ass body
yeah you don't even think about their
penis because they're so big you know
you're just like yeah he's packing it
kind of reminds me of like bodybuilders
when they get all shriveled up from
taking all the steroids right right but
isn't that strange because like the
average like human penis like evolved to
be a lot bigger than a Silverback
Gorilla but there's somehow like that's
so disproportionate to their size and no
one can tell them anything no one he'll
rip you to shreds you know what I mean
he doesn't know he has no clue do you
think he knows that he has a small dick
oh and if he doesn't know does he see
that's that's how we should live our
lives dudes with micro penises you know
there shouldn't be podcasts talking
about their penises you know what I mean
let them live Julian how about when we
did the the live show we did it I did a
show we can I'll say it so you don't
really know what we're talking about but
I did a show with someone a live show
and we asked the audience like to tell
like bad sex stories or bad penis
stories or whatever and every story was
like about a micro dick I'm like you
guys there's not nothing wrong with
people that have Micro penises that's
not the story has to be of like did they
do something bad to you with their penis
did they give you a disease with their
penis or the hole that was underneath
yes
it's just unfortunate it was like oh my
God you guys are evil
it is messed up listen I remember my
micro penis I'll never forget you
you're a nice person when was it was in
college I banged him twice oh it was
bangable size that came back for more I
mean no I honestly was like I gotta I
must be remembering this wrong I went
back what's the equivalent for like a
girl what's like if it's like a micro
penis would be like a larger or no
vaginismus probably but I feel like
that's like a guy's guys probably get
off on that is when the opening of the
vagina is very very very small no
because it would be big
it would be too big for them like hot
dog in the hallway it's too small too
big yeah yeah I think maybe something
that girls would be ashamed of is
probably if we were called like loose or
something like that but I think right
but even loose is you know yeah we can
still turn it back on yeah like talking
about Michael Venus there's nothing
wrong with Michael no but we can turn it
back on you I'm like I'm gonna lose your
dish is small right like we could still
turn it back on you I don't know what
the equivalent is really for us
um no the big clits clits always get big
because when they're in Gorge they look
like but some people have like penis
clits like where they look like penises
really I think so yeah I mean that
sounds worse than micro penis penis
I think it's the same I think they're
probably the same size you know it's
like the same thing yeah
my guy he always had long-term
girlfriends oh really yeah I was always
in Long relationships and he's doing
well that's sweet this is her pleasure
too you know
honestly I wouldn't mind a guy with a
micro penis like that's very low
maintenance for me I'll tell you the
Hogs that day would have been a problem
the Hogs I've did have been a problem
that's been the problem hugs are out I'm
done I'm done we're done with with
anything that is past a certain size no
thank you I'm not a size queen but I was
going to ask you
um about this thing we talked about last
episode with Esther called the good boy
text what is your protocol when you
sleep with a girl how long after do you
always text her like a courteous say
thank you for that that was fun do you
always text her yeah I I because usually
I we do like a date and night so I do
say like yo at a good time you know had
fun you know
what if you don't want to hang out with
her again still nice no I still said a
text yeah because because it's not you
know the text is like pretty close to
afterwards yeah before noon or afternoon
uh I mean sometimes it's just like did
you get home safe or whatever think
something like that you know what I mean
and you could say you had a good time
then
and I feel like like everyone's kind of
like I'm I'm in touch like through
social media like we're still like kind
of following each other you know give a
couple of likes little post likes oh my
God
I'm throwing some post likes over here
you know what I mean it's not just the
hot pictures the the dinners and all of
my photos I even likes to the art photos
I went on a date with this guy and I
accidentally we didn't follow each other
and then I accidentally followed him it
was so embarrassing
then you couldn't even unfollow after
that of course I could I wanted him to
immediately know it was an accident oh
okay but it was and then I accidentally
facetimed him once
oh my God his name started with an A so
he was like at the top it was so
annoying I was like God this guy thinks
I'm obsessed with him damn it Aaron
annoying
it was like and and I FaceTime him and
he called me from Mexico he was
like I'm in Mexico on tour he was like
um what's up I'm like how narcissistic
for you to think I didn't accidentally
FaceTime me I was like butt uh how is he
supposed to know but what but don't I
don't know why would I out all of a
sudden I want to date with you and then
I'm FaceTiming like two months later
it was crazy and he was like what's up
like it was down to I feel like
there's you know I guess that was a nice
thing I shouldn't be mad even if you
don't if immediately after you feel like
you're probably not gonna see that
person again like if you give it a few
months in between you kind of might want
to you know hit them up again you know
what my issue with him was he was in he
was in town he was a musician he was in
town and
um
we had a good first aid and then he was
in town like doing an album and he would
not stop texting me he texted me
constantly okay oh man wouldn't stop
Tech which was fine it was like cool I
like to text I'm funny on text and stuff
and we're always vibing on text and the
date was really fun and then he was like
I really want to hang out with you again
and then he wouldn't he would never hang
out with me and I'm like that's very
annoying that is annoying I'm like you
just one or the other it's all good it's
like whatever but you don't need to text
me every it was like constant
communication I was like okay do you
wanna hang out
and then he'd be like I'm doing I'm
recording or I'm you know I'm in an
intent I'm like I do an intense thing
too like that's definitely like uh
it was like narcissistic boy kind of
thing it was very weird it was probably
getting all of the dopamine hit but I
would have been like I wasn't a bad like
I'm like I would have like I could have
been your girl I could have
received that or whatever it was just
like a noise it was like either way just
be up front with whatever it's gonna be
it's like don't it was just such an
annoying I was like do you want to hang
on and then he'd be like you left your
sunglasses I was like all right do you
want to throw them in the trash or bring
them to me there's options here and
either's all good but then then I
faced them and three months
later how embarrassing that is
I finally was just like dude I'm done
you know that's why musicians are kind
of they play games or they're they're
easiest to be like players because you
used excuse in the studio that could be
anything anytime you could be out at
four in the morning
I have used it just being like I'm at
the studio and you sound cool you sound
like oh I'm doing this intense thing you
don't know when that's gonna end you're
if you're in the studio it could be an
all-night thing we could be done in 30
minutes you know so I'm like I don't get
fine but why do you keep texting
me from the studio then why are you why
don't you focus on your work I'm
I'm writing a album too that's
true that album's gonna be trash I'm
texting yeah I'm like Jesus Christ I
perform every night I know what you do
that's I do I do really love that like
when I'm involved with a girl who has
her own creative Endeavors and stuff
like that you can't play that with
them you know something like they really
help yeah you can't play that like right
it was so weird I think he just liked
having someone to talk like talk to I
don't know he liked the attention or
something but it was like oh my God so
then when he was like what's up I'm in
Mexico I'm like
what would I possibly want to FaceTime
you about yeah yeah yeah is that
something that you
um have rules against like say for Bobby
say for instance like he does not feel
like it's right for him to date a comic
um is there do you have rules against
like dating someone who's like a
musician no I've dated a musician I've
dated a musician girl like way bigger
than me you know and it was like if you
know I was like carrying around her
shopping bags around Korea and like no
autographs fans chill bro she's busy
like I did the whole thing I don't I'm
really if you saw a lot of my exes
there's been like no there's no
consistency like far as looks and and
what they are like I one thing that I
like is I do like boss women and like
women who are doing things you know so
it's like every girl I've dated like
like a real popping musician to like
really successful fashion photographer
this that but that's like the only thing
you look at them they're like all over
the place you know
um but I I know as far as rules like
that I don't think I have a single rule
like that I've you know I've
been bullied into relationships you know
I've I've just done it you know
um I'm very disciplined like I'm willing
to go for it yeah even though I kind of
don't want it sometimes too how does one
get bullied into a relief I if I knew
that was a thing do you know how many
relationships I would have had
when I was younger
Esther's a bully into a relationship
you're right Esther I remember when she
would tell me like things that she would
she would say to her boyfriends and
stuff I'd be like that's crazy and it
would always work I'm like oh my god it
worked but it works right I was always
like yeah whatever I mean I guess yeah
because our mistake was playing like the
cool girl like oh you can't hurt me yeah
like you don't want to be with me yeah
and then I had to go to so many of my
best friend's weddings I was like yeah I
was young I was like okay wait but um
how how did you get bullied into your
relationships just I mean you know I
think they've
had very strong personalities and
they just I don't know it just naturally
kind of happened I wasn't planning or
anything next year I will wake up and
I'm like oh now I'm living in New York
you know it's like it's like in her
apartment you can't leave yeah it was
just what I mean and also I think the
texting thing like I I've been with a
lot of like very aggressive texters and
I I respond you know next thing you know
I'm talking like throughout the day good
morning good night my life I know yeah
now it's like a minute you know what I
mean it's like every 15 minutes or
something you know I was like here's a
bookstore cool bookstore you know I'm
like oh that's a cool bookstore yeah
it's like it's throughout the day you
know and I'm very like minimal you know
I've always been like that but I get
kind of like pressured a little bit you
know I've had this girl like write me
like we I had this fling when I was in
my early 20s in Korea I met her there
and afterwards she was like let's just
continue to write letters to each other
like no emails or texts and for like two
years we just wrote letters to each
other two years yeah but and we made
like a Zine out of it like last year it
was real cute and stuff but like but
like every letter she remembers
Sebastian and Bean or something Sabine
and some do you remember those books
that were like letters to each other oh
my God romantic was it like yes you know
what I'm talking about no I know I don't
anyways she wrote a letter um and her
letters were always like three four
pages and I was like just sitting with
an empty piece of paper like oh God damn
I gotta make this letter better than
hers did you feel obligated sometimes
well not obligated but it was just like
I felt like I have to keep up with like
how romantic her letters were you know
it is you had to at least match the
energy or the effort yeah like hers was
crazy it's like I'm sitting in a Subway
right now across from me it's this 90
year old man who's blah blah blah oh my
God that's so but you know what she
probably made you a better writer yeah
probably yeah you had a lot of practice
two years of having to do that but it's
like you read that Zine and her letters
seem like so sophisticated and mines are
like from like it sounds like a 14 year
old wrote it or something and I was like
22. yeah oh that's so dope I love that
yeah you're totally gonna do that to
someone now no okay I've definitely
snail mailed with people before and I've
snail trailed with a few but there there
have been times where I'm like I do
think that there is a thing of like over
communicating and calling each other a
little bit too much and you're just sort
of too en mesh that like you almost
leave no space for anything else like so
there I have dated a guy I I had I was
dating a guy where I was like hey just
write me letters and this was the first
that was
the first time I really got to know him
was through letters because in our
day-to-day interactions I don't think he
felt as free to really kind of because
I'm I can be an overpowering person he
was more of an introvert yeah and um
maybe I led the conversation a lot
and but when his letters came in I was
like this person's incredible like I
found out things about him that I would
have never found out even in our
day-to-day stuff right so like maybe
there is something to that that's super
cute yeah and I was it was cool I'm glad
we did it now now that we have this like
Zane and stuff and looking back at that
time what was the end result of that
like you guys get together at the end I
just saw recently on this Korea trip nah
she's like with some dude um that she
wants to marry but he has his own set of
problems and I heard all about it it was
cool oh so now you're always gonna have
to hear about everything you're her pen
pal I have a friend now yeah this was
called they were called Sabine and
Sebastian and they were like letters
like love letters written to each other
and you would on
they were like envelopes in the book and
you would open the envelope and like
pull the letter out it was cool oh if
you think about it there's no really
version of that like love letters now or
people are probably writing like long
things to each other now right and what
my therapist said was really she was
like you know because I was like well
why can't I just journal on my computer
put it on my phone and she was like no
no no
um the reason that writing is important
is because it slows down especially for
someone like me I always have swirling
ideas and it makes you more like focused
and more present in what you're actually
writing and feeling like there's a more
of a correlation to your feeling like
you're not because sometimes when I
write my head is too far past my body or
my feel you know what I mean yeah to
write something that you know someone's
gonna read and receive yeah as opposed
to I didn't like to even tell guys how I
felt at night time because like in the
morning I might not feel that way so
imagine like the time the letter gets
there you're like
genuinely one of the worst feelings ever
when you overcome it and then you wake
up in the morning you're like what even
telling someone you don't love but in
the in the throes of passion and the
throes of the moment you tell them you
love them back and you're like I don't
me I didn't mean that or how about those
relationship you were getting where you
would make all these future plans like
you'd get so into them yeah in the
beginning you make all the future plans
and then you wake up and you're like
this ain't my life I'm not doing this
engagements it gets broken up broken off
all the time you know there's no like
you can't commit anymore I unsent the
message like yesterday yeah what did it
say what did it say this one this wasn't
a relationship thing this was a dude who
was annoying the out of me in Korea
right like just a random dude I know
from back home
and he was annoying a lot of my friends
he's lingering just inserting himself a
conversation we had this conversation
with all our friends like you know so I
was trying to
tell him not to come to this party that
I was throwing in Korea I was I I wrote
out a whole thing like bro like I think
it's best that you don't come to the
party respectfully all this thing in the
road paragraph and I sent it and I
copied it and put it in my group chat to
see what my friends thought they were
like nah you need to unsend that fam
that sounds crazy and I was like for
real and I unsented and like he's like
and they're like yeah that's also a
receipt you should call him and tell him
that you know but did he do you
know if he read it no he didn't read it
oh he came to the party I didn't know
that I decided not to invite him but
that's a good case of like probably
unsending you know I felt but the only
risk with unsending is they saw it and
then they left it unseen you know how
you can like scroll and if they get an
alert then they can technically
screenshot right there and see part of
it yeah I've also unsent like texts that
I've gotten ghosted from a girl like if
it's sitting there for a while I'm like
okay now this is thirsty I'm unsending
that oh if it's just sitting there or
not it's sitting there and it's time
passes I'm like oh she's just not trying
to click on this yeah Andrew Keegan I'm
gonna unsend inviting you to do traffic
he already saw it yeah but I'm still
gonna unsend it okay but if it's so even
if she's already seen it you'll unsend
it no no no no scene it's it's out there
there's something like there's something
power in taking back a scene though I
don't know
I don't mean this anymore do you
remember who Andrew Keegan uh who's that
again okay he was the guy from yeah 10
Things I Hate About You was he an
independence day no he wasn't he wasn't
just kidding guys oh yeah yeah yeah he
was in uh Camp Nowhere Camp Nowhere
I love cab nowhere I love Cam Newton
yeah yeah thank you so Annie
um I saw him in Venice he had a cold
that I would have joined I always
thought this guy was cool as hell
pictures up I loved him we were talking
about him then I saw him in Venice I saw
him and he was like with his family so I
didn't want to say anything so the idea
I go okay I'm going to take this as a
sign idea to come on trash Tuesday I set
up a really nice message yeah
but I think that he got into some issue
with like the feds for like illegal
kombucha right
for his cold I did say I was like I did
mention the call I was like I wish it
was still around so I could have joined
it but generally genuinely like do we
give a about illegal kombucha like
that's not a cancelable effect literally
who cares and also just everyone does
colds who cares every morning I wake up
I try I pray for the strength to I go
Annie do not start and only fans and do
not start a cold do not start an only
fans it's we could all do it okay yeah
his call looks pretty well put together
that's awesome everyone's cute it's like
a spiritual place where they drink
Fedora what part of a cult would you be
like what member would you be I would be
Sheila
Sheila in have you guys seen the bhagwan
documentary The Osho yeah
um maybe like the drizzling just yes the
secretary then overtakes yeah the cult
leader I think I'd be the guy like the
you know the person who's worried about
where the Cults headed they did not that
wouldn't be me I'd be the person they
talk to like I think we should leave I'm
like nah I'm saying bro yeah I'm not
like I'm too scared I'm chilling you
know like and I'd probably snitch on
them I'm like yeah I would be that dude
right there he's trying to get up I
would be the leader and I would be the
one that was like
Sheila go mix this Kool-Aid you'd be
mother God
I would be I would be the Teal Swan yeah
Teal Swan you're telling everyone to
ingest toxic amounts of silver yes no
mother God was the the love is one
um lady she eventually died she was like
blue because she kept eating silver
but then I love when when Cole uh
leaders like override all science
they're like no no if you just believe
the silver is good for you and then like
yeah but like Heaven's Gate right the
whole thing was like if you wear like
purple and wear like Nike Cortez's like
you're gonna get shot out into whatever
Planet they believed in is that cutie
pick Nikes Cortez's specifically yes if
you wear what this is just like a Laker
fan
it always is
one
Nike and the notorious Heaven's Gate
suicide
yeah but they um
at first Nike was like this is pretty
cool and I go wait no no no no
yeah but uh is this a Nike campaign
that's what happened
oh my God I think this is so cool I
think bring back all those funky little
Cults I mean
Scientology is still killing it Cults
are going great listen I joined a call
I'm like
I'm in Cults all the time will you tell
me a cool one if you get into it I
always get out of them here's the
problem I always become friends with the
leader and then I go you're not that
good I feel like they're different like
crypto that you know the crypto crew is
like that that's all cultish a little
bit too you know yeah
Financial Cults yeah that's a thing
right
um
yeah
well this is great this was so fun this
was so fun thank you for enlightening us
about
um post-sex manners and pre-sex washes I
was more enlightened I think we all gave
a little and and took a little today I
think we I'm putting my microwave to use
oh my God the microwave is where I'll
never get over it I'm telling you guys
rice cooker there's always a rice cooker
you know what I can see I can see you
coming over to our guys house with a
rice cooker and like plugging it in okay
there's only one brand that I swear by
like all of these fancy newer ones I
hate tiger the old school tiger ones the
white ones with the floral pattern on it
nothing Cooks better rice everything new
will never compare so unless you have it
if I see a guy he has a tiger rice
cooker I'm marrying him you know what I
like I like the idea of like someone
coming on your back and then they just
take like a wad of rice and have the
rice soak it up
like a wet iPhone
here you go
a little uh it's become sticky rice
I don't have a rice cooker
what do you still go old school with the
rice cooker I've never cooked rice in my
life you and Bobby both what is your
actual problem right you had it cooked
for you though haven't you I have I I
have instant rice yeah I mean I just put
it in a microwave oh my God this is rice
cookers are pretty instant ricey though
they don't they do you don't know the
rice finger rule what's the rice what is
it Asian comedian bits what is it a rice
finger roll is basically where the water
has to come up to in relation to the
rice so you can just eyeball
um the correct amount of water versus
like measuring it out you know I I grew
up I remember that though so this is my
tiger yeah that's that's I have the
three cup I have the five cup it's so
cute yeah this is this is it guys this
is the winner nothing wipes come better
than this right here
[Laughter]
you guys thank you so much for being
here this week dumb this was so
fun thank you guys come back anytime and
is there anything you want to plug no uh
fun with dumb every Wednesday
um that's our podcast and uh yeah that's
it cool we're trying to get stuffy on
yeah that'd be great yeah Stuffy's so
freaking great all right guys we'll see
you next week thank you thanks guys
[Music]
foreign